GUY CHARUSADHIRAKUL:
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
Hope you all had a nice
lunch on this beautiful day.
In the next hours,
we have a few talks
about how developers like
you can create great games,
connect, and scale to
billions of users with Google.
My name is Guy, and I'm
a partner development
manager with the Google Play
team from Southeast Asia.
I'm based in Singapore.
And also I have my
colleague Daniel who
will join me shortly as well.
In this first session,
we'll share with you
how game developers can achieve
success in emerging markets
and build great business there.
We'll cover a few
things in this talk.
First, we'll share with you
opportunities and challenges
that emerging markets represent.
Then we'll share with you three
key strategies for achieving
success in these markets.
We'll also share
with you resources
that you can take away to
help you achieve that goal.
The reason we want to talk
to you about emerging market
because we know it is a
big business opportunities
for game developers.
However, these
markets may not be
as familiar to many of you
who may have been focused
a bit more on developed
markets, like the US market,
Europe, Japan, and Korea.
But first, let's talk about what
do we mean by emerging markets.
Emerging markets are
countries and regions
that are in growth stage.
And they share some
common characteristics.
These markets have large and
fast-growing smartphone user
base.
Income level of users
in these markets
are growing rapidly,
although they might be lower
in developed market, typically
maybe a quarter to a third.
In these markets, we also see
much higher proportion of entry
or mid-level devices
with lower specs.
Credit card ownership and
usage in these markets
are also lower.
Geographically, emerging
markets cover a very large area
and include key markets
like India, Southeast Asia,
Latin America, Middle
East, and North Africa.
As I mentioned, emerging markets
have a lot of smartphone users
that is growing rapidly.
Of the 4 billion
forecasted Android devices
that's projected to be in the
markets over next few years,
many of them are already
in emerging markets.
2/3 of Android
devices sold today
are already in emerging markets.
And this represents a huge
opportunity for developers
to tap into a very
large user base.
And the good news
is it's not just
the number of smartphone
users in these markets.
We're seeing very strong
momentum in in-app purchases
and monetization in
these markets as well.
Today, among the top 20
grossing markets on Google Play,
seven of them are
emerging markets.
Consumer spending
in these markets
is also growing rapidly.
They have doubled in
the past two years
and continue to
grow rapidly also.
Now, I hope that you are
excited about the opportunities
in emerging markets.
And we'd like to share with
you three key strategies
for helping you to become
successful in these regions.
First, you should consider
optimizing your games
for entry and mid-level
smartphones in emerging
markets.
Two, consider localizing
and culturalizing your games
for users in these markets
where English may not
be the first language.
And three, consider adjusting
price points for your games
so that they are more affordable
for users in these markets.
We'll go through each of
these in more details.
And I'll start with optimizing
your games for smartphones
in emerging markets.
In emerging markets, user
really care about the app size.
This is often because
entry-level phones
in emerging markets
come with lower storage.
Or sometimes data connectivity
is just expensive,
so it's costly for users in
this market to download apps.
And we've seen this
translate to user concerns.
In Indonesia, half of the
users have told us in a survey
that they really want to know
how much data an app will use
or how much space an app
will take on their phone.
In Brazil, we have heard
many users mentioned
that they don't download
apps or they don't end up
purchasing premium games
because they run out
of space on their phones.
And it's not just user concerns.
We have seen this translate to
metrics that impact developer
performance.
In emerging markets, we
have seen the larger apps
result in lower
download success rates.
For every 10 megabyte
increase in APK size,
developer sees 1.5 percentage
drop in app install conversion.
So let's say if your game
is 60 megabytes larger
than a similar games,
which, at a first glance,
doesn't seem like a lot.
But you could actually see up
to 10 percentage point lower
install conversion
in emerging markets.
That translates to a lot of
install that you're losing.
Therefore, it's important
to keep your app's size
light for emerging markets.
And it's not just about
optimizing the app size
as well.
It's also important
in emerging markets
to optimize the game performance
once the user has downloaded
the app onto a device.
This is because entry-level
devices in emerging markets
often don't have
a lot of memory.
We have seen that nearly one in
two devices in emerging markets
have RAM less than
two gigabytes.
So if your game is
memory intensive,
this could lead to crashes,
poor rendering, and poor user
experience for users
in these markets.
We're seeing many developers
putting in efforts
to optimize their games
for emerging markets.
And "Garena Free Fire"
is one great example.
"Free Fire" is a popular
battle royale game,
but it comes in a size that's
just under 600 megabytes
while some of the other
games in this genre
is over one gigabyte.
The games also offer
Google Play Instant,
where users can immediately
play and experience
a game without having to
download and install the APK.
The game is also optimized to
support over 12,000 devices
on a play device catalog.
And as a result of
all these efforts,
the game is able to reach many,
many users in emerging markets.
It has reached over 40 million
peak daily active user.
And the game has gone on to
become the number one grossing
game in many emerging markets,
like Brazil, Indonesia,
and Thailand.
I hope that convinced
you of the importance
of optimizing your games
for emerging markets.
And here are some tips and tools
that can help you with that.
First, try to reduce
your APK and app size.
And you can use Android
app bundles that
was mentioned earlier
today, as well as
APK Analyzer in Android Studio.
Secondly, consider
optimizing the performance
for devices with lower RAM.
Our team has
published a Building
for Billions guidelines
to help you do just that.
And we'll share with
you the link to that
at the end of the presentation.
Next, consider publishing Google
Play Instant for your game.
Again, this lets users try
and experience your game
without having to download
and install the APK.
And if you develop
in Unity, there
is a Unity plug-in to
help you with that.
Finally, check to make
sure how widely your game
is supported across various
devices in emerging markets.
And you can use device
catalog in the Play Console
to help you with that.
Next, Daniel will share with
you two other key strategies
to help you become successful
in emerging markets.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: [? Welcome. ?]
DANIEL TROCOLI: Hello, everyone.
Our second strategy is
related to localization
and culturalization of your
games for emerging markets.
Localization is really, really
important for these markets.
And the reason for that is
that the English proficiency
is really low.
So it isn't a surprise that
when we check the top 20
grossing titles
in these regions,
the vast majority of them
are localized in not only
[? into ?] store listings
but specifically in game.
KLab saw a very positive
impact from the localization
they did of "Captain
Tsubasa" to Arabic.
They released the localized
version during Ramadan
and the World Cup of 2018.
And as a culturalization effort,
they added Saudi Arabia players
to that.
As a result, they saw that their
installs increased sevenfold.
And the current
revenues that they
see from Arabic-speaking
countries
exceeds their ones from
English-speaking countries.
Another aspect to take
in mind is the packaging
of your game for
emerging markets.
And by packaging, I
mean the store listings.
They need to be adapted
to the local preferences.
Supercell does a great job
by adopting their screenshots
to the cultural tastes
of each country.
Here you can see the difference
between the Brazilian one
versus the Japanese one.
So, some tips for localizing.
Adapt your packaging.
And in order to do this, we
provide you the store listing
experiment tool where you can
try different configurations
of your store listing, and
also the country targeting tool
so you can have different
store listing for each country.
Also, try to understand cultural
references and special dates.
These will generate
several interesting sites
so you can create
custom events, custom
content, and special sales that
are tailored to each market.
Also, each country has its
preferred marketing channels
and social networks that
provide more traction there.
So be sure to understand
the digital landscape.
And working with some
digital agencies there
might speed up your
learning curve.
And our last strategy relates
to adjusting your price point
for emerging markets.
As different countries have
different levels of income
per capita and, consequently,
different levels of purchasing
power, some successful
products and services
already adapt their price
points to the local realities.
And in emerging markets,
there is usually
less disposable income for
entertainment products.
So the users there might face
some interesting decisions.
Shall I buy some
jams, or shall I
buy one month of a
streaming video service?
Shall I buy a nice burger combo,
or this [? customization ?]
product [? moving ?] in game?
So here we would
like to provide you
with some of the most common
price points for these goods,
specifically for Brazil,
Mexico, Thailand, and Indonesia.
And it isn't a surprise
that when we check it
that the price points that drive
the majority of the [? heavy ?]
and emerging markets,
they are more
friendly to the
local population.
So there is
effectively a trade-off
between the average revenue per
paying user for a broader buyer
base.
And when we compare
the price points that
generate half of the
revenue in emerging markets,
they are usually in a range of
10% to 25% of the price points
that generate half of the
revenue on developed markets.
IGG has a very
interesting case, where
they applied more friendly
pricing for Brazil.
So in general, they charge
$2 for the starter pack.
But specifically
for Brazil, they
started pricing at $0.99 cents.
And with this, they got
122% growth in consumer
spend in country.
"Garena Free Fire" as well
offered different price points,
depending on the emerging
market that they are.
So the price points can range
from 10% to 20% of the prices
that they usually charge
on developed markets.
And this doubled their
buyer penetration.
As some general tips, it's
important to understand
what is the acceptable price
points for some emerging
markets.
Recall that as people have
less disposable income,
they will be always comparing
their entertainment options.
So use AB testing to try to
find your optimal pricing
for each country.
It's worth it to remember
that Google Play allows
you to charge prices that
are below $1 17 countries.
And the majority
of these countries
are on emerging markets.
So this can broaden
up your price range
that can be tested
through AB testing.
Also, avoid biases.
In emerging markets as well,
we do have wealthy people.
And there is a broad range of
users that you can monetize.
So to find the right
mix of [INAUDIBLE]
or having your mix between
ads, IAP, and subscription.
Thank you for your
attention today,
and here are some links
that you might find useful.
Respectively, the Building
for Business website,
more information
about Android vitals,
and the link for the
translation services that you
might find within Play Console.
And next, I'd like
to introduce you
to Vijay, who will share
some updates on how
to build AR games.
Thank you.
VIJAY SHANKAR: Good afternoon.
It's great to be here at GDC.
I'm Vijay Shankar and
I lead product ARCore.
Today, I want to
talk about how ARCore
can help you build more
compelling gaming experiences.
But first, let's start with
a simple question, like,
why even build an AR game?
I believe the answer,
both from a gaming
and an overall
computing perspective,
is that this gets users a
more engaging experience when
the digital and the
physical worlds intersect.
This, if you're
able to accomplish
the intersection of the
digital and the physical world,
opens the door for more
engaging experiences
that I think are going to be a
lot more realistic, a lot more
intuitive for users to
play, and, more importantly,
a lot more fun.
Speaking of fun, if you look
at the history of gaming,
predominantly, games and the
magic that's come from games
has been the ability to pull
users from the real world
into the digital one.
But now, with augmented reality,
you can actually flip that.
You can bring the imagination
and the fantasy right
to the users in their
own physical space.
We think that's
extremely powerful.
As I'm sure you all
would agree, that's
a lot easier said than done.
So we've been giving
a lot of thought
into what are the key
ingredients required
from a tech
enablement perspective
to make compelling
gaming experiences in AR.
And we think there are
three underlying ones.
Number one is the game and the
tech needs to be perceptive.
What does this mean?
In order to augment
reality, you need
to be able to have your device
understand the places, object,
and people around you.
And number two is immersion.
For something to be
immersive, the virtual objects
in your gaming experience
need to blend seamlessly
into the user's environment.
This is what makes your gaming
experience more realistic.
And three, which we think
is equally important,
is all AR experiences need to
be available across devices
and platforms, be
it iOS or Android.
If you look at the real
world, building perceptive,
immersive, and
accessible experiences
is fairly straightforward.
We don't even
think much about it
because it's
intuitive and natural.
But for the camera in our mobile
devices, it's not so much.
And that's the reason
we built ARCore.
We want to give you
simple yet powerful tools
to help connect the physical
and the digital world.
Now let's actually dig in
into some of these tools
and how they can enable you to
build compelling experiences.
So let's first start
with perception.
Like we had discussed, there
are three underlying areas
that we need to
enable for perception.
The ability for the device to
understand places, objects,
and then people.
Everything starts with places
and environmental understanding
with AR.
With ARCore, out of the
box, you get the ability
to understand the physical
structure of the environment.
The ability to detect
horizontal, vertical,
and angular surfaces.
So it may be a wall,
the ground, or a table.
We have you covered in terms
of our ability to find a plane.
And over the last year
since we announced
environmental
understanding in ARCore,
we have made
significant progress
in terms of how the
underlying tech works.
We have put a lot of
attention into looking
at what are the things about
this that actually move
user engagement and retention.
And we have
significantly improved
some of those core metrics.
These could be things such
as the probability of finding
planes, or the time
it takes for your user
defined that first plane
to create that aha moment.
So we are super
excited to see how
these changes are
going to help you
build more compelling games.
Let's now talk about objects.
One example is the
augmented images API.
This helps you track
and recognize 2D images
and then be able to
kick off immersive
3D experiences off of them.
And all we need from
you is to give us
a database of the images and
the associated 3D content
you want to trigger.
It's that simple.
And this unlocks
the ability for you
to create immersive
experiences around the user
by tapping into everyday things.
It could be a poster
or a cereal box.
So we spoke about
places and objects.
Let's talk about
faces and people,
which are a lot more complex.
Even the smallest of
movements and changes,
like the arch of an
eyebrow, can drastically
change the meaning in
the expression someone
is trying to convey.
And which is why we are super
excited about the augmented
faces API that we
launched last month.
It is a high quality
468-point 3D mesh
that can detect even
the minutest of actions
that users take, and then
trigger powerful experiences
off of them.
We're really excited to
see some of the experiences
you can build with
augmented faces API.
These were some examples of
the perceptive capabilities
in ARCore.
Let's now talk about immersion.
As we had discussed
earlier, for something
to feel like it's
actually with you,
this could be a gaming
element or a character.
For it to actually
feel real, it needs
to move and react to the
real world environment,
just like you and I or
a real object would.
And that is a
really hard problem.
I want to talk about
a couple of things
that ARCore does to make
that happen seamlessly.
The first one is
motion tracking.
By combining the data from
the camera and the IMU,
we are able to provide
your device the capability
to have both position
and orientation,
and track itself with respect
to the rest of the real world.
And this actually enables
your camera and your device
to perform and work
like your own eyes.
And again, this
is one area where
we have made significant
improvements since we
launched this last year.
And the second one I want
to talk about with immersion
is lighting.
We need to really
get lighting right
or it breaks the illusion.
The virtual content in
your gaming experiences
need to react to the same way to
changes in real world lighting
like real objects would.
And that's a hard problem.
And you get that out
of the box with ARCore.
So we spoke about some of
the perceptive and immersive
capabilities.
And I want to talk
about how ARCore
is making this more
accessible, and why
that's equally importantly.
I'm sure we all
would agree, gaming
is inherently more
fun with your friends.
And especially
when we are trying
to connect the digital
and the physical worlds,
being able to share
these gaming experiences
in the real world with people
you like is extremely crucial.
And that's exactly what
Cloud Anchors does.
This lets you have shared
gaming experiences no matter
the device that
your friends use.
It works on iOS and Android.
And we think this is extremely
powerful to scale gaming
experiences, and for people
to get the most out of it.
This is a fundamentally
hard technical problem.
And the thing that we have
done again with ARCore
is we've completely
abstracted that,
so that you as
developers don't have
to worry about creating the
anchor, or hosting the anchors,
or even resolving the anchors.
And it's super
straightforward for you
to enable these shared
multiplayer experiences
within your gaming sessions.
The other piece of
feedback that we
have gotten over
the last year is
building these high quality
interactions is actually
extremely hard.
Right?
This is a new concept,
and it's fairly complex.
So one of the things that
we heard from developers
is, we would like [? to ?] not
spend as much time worrying
about these interactions,
but spend more time
on what we do best, which
is building the gaming
experience itself.
And this is why we spend
a lot of time thinking
through these interactions.
And we launched the AR
Elements Design Guidelines app
to make this extremely
simple for you to tap into.
So this app is a collection of
the underlying UX primitives
and principles
that you would need
to build all these high
quality AR interactions.
For example, this
could be, how do you
help users understand
motion tracking
and help them find their first
plane in an engaging way?
Or how do you make this simple
and interesting for your users
to start a shared
multiplayer session?
So we have talked through all
those little details based
on our experience at Google
building first party AR
experiences and speaking
with a lot of developers who
work on AR experiences overall.
So we're really excited
to share this with you.
And we would love to
hear your feedback
on what more you would like
to see around these design
guidelines.
So you can get this app
today on the Play Store.
Or you can also get it
as part of the Unity SDK.
The other thing I
want to call out,
continuing on the
theme of accessibility,
is ARCore is available
with our SDKs
on Unity, Unreal, Android, and
iOS, like we had spoken about.
We want to make it
super easy for you
to work on the platform
of your choice,
and make it super simple
for you to get started.
Today, ARCore is available
on over 250 million devices.
And that number continues
to grow as we speak.
I just want to bring
this back together
with a couple of examples
to illustrate what
we have been talking about.
The first two here,
"Jurassic World Alive"
and "Walking Dead",
are examples where
they combine the power of ARCore
and the Google Maps platform
to build amazing
content and gaming
experiences to the real world.
The other one is one of
my personal favorites
from Tender Claws,
which is about how
do you use players' facial
expressions to control
the game-play and
use the emotions
and expressions to
control virtual objects
within the game.
And while you're
at GDC this week,
I would highly encourage
you to go check
out the ARCore booth, where we
have an escape the room AR demo
that is super
compelling and gives you
a flavor for what
magic happens when
you connect the digital
and the physical world.
And we have everything
you need to get started,
from documentation to Codelabs.
So we encourage you to go
to developers.google.com/AR
to start building
your AR game today.
And I'll finally
end on this note.
Historically, if you have
looked at every new emerging
technology, you
as game developers
have been at the forefront
of pushing the tech forward.
And we think it's going
to be the same with AR.
So we on the ARCore
team are really
excited to see what are
the compelling experiences
that you're going to
build with ARCore.
Thank you.
LISA TAKEHANA: Hi there.
My name is Lisa Takehana, and
I'm a game designer at Google.
And today, I'm
going to be talking
about a different kind
of game that you can
play on your mobile devices.
And it's a fairly
new industry still.
And that's voice games.
And specifically,
I'm going to be
talking about designing voice
games for the Google Assistant
platform.
In the next 15
minutes, I'm going
to be talking about why
we think voice games are
on the rise, and the potential
we see in this market.
And then we're going to be
sharing a couple of games
that we built at Google.
And lastly, we want to
share a lot of the learnings
that we went through when we
were designing these games.
Again, it's a
fairly new industry,
and there's still
a lot of unknowns.
And there's a lot
of trial and error
when we were
developing these games.
Let me introduce you to
the Google Assistant, which
is Google's virtual helper
controlled by your voice.
The devices you see here have
the Google Assistant built in,
which means it has a
microphone for voice input,
and also speaker for
the devices to respond.
These devices are collectively
known in the industry
as smart speakers.
So in 2016, it began
with the Google Home,
which is the Google Assistant
with the speaker only.
But then it expanded to
other types of hardware
depending on
different user needs.
So for example, we have
the Google Home Mini,
which is a smaller version
of the Google Home.
And this one has a
better price point.
And then we also have
the Google Home Max,
which is a larger version
with better speakers.
Last year, we also introduced
the Google Home Hub,
which is the Google Assistant
with a visual display built
in, but still powered
by your voice.
And as with any new
media technology,
it takes some time for
users to get used to them.
Here's a graph
showing adoption rates
of all the different types
of new media that came out.
So for example,
we have cable TV,
smartphones, and internet
over the past half a century.
And then you can see on
the bottom right here,
those are smart speakers.
And you can still see that it's
in pretty early stages in terms
of user adoption.
And what are these users doing
with these smart speakers?
Well, based on this
research by Adobe,
we know that most
users are using them
for things like media.
So maybe listening
to music or listening
to a podcast or the news.
But we also know
that they're using it
for things like productivity.
So those are going to be things
like checking your calendar,
asking for the weather.
But we also know that there
is a fairly large user
base of people who are
asking for fun things.
So for example, you can
ask the Google Assistant
what its favorite color is, what
kind of food it likes to eat,
what kind of animal it likes.
And we also have games available
on the Google Assistant
that you can play.
And these are really great
platforms for multiplayer
because they're
designed to be placed
in communal areas in the home.
So this is a really great device
that you can put in, let's say,
a living room or a kitchen.
So this is a really great
multiplayer platform
for family game
night or if you want
to play games with your
friends and roommates
on a Friday night.
We built a couple
of multiplayer games
that we're showcasing here
using the Google Assistant.
The first one is a trivia game
called "Are You Feeling Lucky?"
And this is an experience
that's available on all Google
Assistant surfaces,
but it's best
played on the Home Hub,
which we launched last year,
with a visual display.
And in this trivia game, you
have the Google Assistant
asking the users questions and
acting as a game show host.
And you have this
back-and-forth interaction.
And, of course, we also
have a [? class of ?] game,
"Mad Libs", that's also
available on the Google
Assistant.
So again, fairly new industry.
There is a lot of
trial and error.
And there was a lot
of growing pains
that came about when we were
trying to design these games.
There aren't a lot of voice
games out there still.
And so we wanted to share
some of the tips and tricks
that we learned while we were
developing these games so
that you can take
these learnings home
and try to build your
own exciting voice games.
So, as with any
game, you first want
to think about what the core
mechanic of your game is.
Simply put, what kind of
game are you building?
But when you have your voice as
the controller and the feedback
being audio only, this
can be pretty tricky
and pretty challenging.
So for example, games
like trivia and quizzes
are a little bit more
intuitive to build for voice
because there's less
information that users
need to retain while
they're playing these games.
So with "Are You
Feeling Lucky?",
the trivia game where you have
the Google Assistant playing
as the host, the
only information
that the users
really need to retain
in this back-and-forth exchange
is probably just the question
and maybe the answer options.
The progression is linear.
We're not really introducing
a lot of complex characters.
We don't really
have crazy worlds
that you're
exploring, which makes
it really easy for players to
track even without visuals.
On the other hand,
when you're trying
to build a game like, let's say,
chess, where it's very visual
and you want to check all
the pieces, or an RPG,
you might have a
lot of characters.
And those characters
might have stats.
And you might have all
these different worlds
that you're exploring and
all these objects that you're
interacting with, which makes
it a little bit trickier when
players don't have a visual
reference in front of them.
I'm not discouraging you from
designing these types of games.
I'm just saying that it
could be a little bit more
challenging without maybe
asking the players to take
notes along the way.
Setting the stage
or the narrative
plays a really crucial
part in any game.
But there's another
layer to this challenge
when you're designing
a voice game,
and that's figuring out
what role the narrator plays
in your game.
So when I mentioned
the trivia game,
again, we have this game
show host type of game.
And the Google Assistant
is your game show host.
Inversely, if you have a game
like a Halloween-themed game,
then maybe your narrator
is a ghost story zombie.
If you have a Christmas
game, maybe it's Santa Claus.
Either way, you
have this character
who is driving the
narrative of your game.
And this is the character
that the players
are going to be interacting
with throughout the game.
This is the character that will
be leading you and revealing
plot points in the game.
And identifying who
this narrator is
and giving this
narrator a character
will be the key to building
a really cohesive world
for your audio game.
The third tip is,
now that you have
the world and the
character that drives it,
you want to start writing
the script or the dialogue
that the characters
and the players
will be reciting back and forth.
As I mentioned earlier, because
the player input is voice
and the output is audio,
the key to writing
a successful dialogue
is keeping it simple so
that players can retain
all that information
and keep track of the game.
The best way for you to tell
if a game is too complex
is by prototyping
by role-playing.
So you can ask someone
to sit down and read
the lines of the narrator.
And the player can try
to respond naturally
as they can to see if there
are any holes in your script
or your dialogue.
If you see that the
player is getting
stuck in parts of
the game, you can
tell that maybe your
game is too complex
and that the dialogue is
not quite written well
as you like it to be.
So at this point in your voice
game, the only thing you have
is dialogue, which
is a little bit dull.
So we want to be adding a
little bit more richness
into your game.
And you can really
accomplish this, of course,
because it's an audio
game by sound design.
And we split this up into
two different categories.
One is background music.
And this could be
a musical track
or it could be something
that's more ambient.
So for example, if you
have your Halloween game,
maybe it's just wind or water
or something of that sort.
And then you also
have sound effects.
So now you want to be
adding the rustling leaves
and things like that.
You could also use the sound
effects to not only identify
objects that are in your
game, but also use them
as player cues as well.
By itself, again, the dialogue
could feel really dull.
So you want to be
adding these layers in
to add a lot more richness into
the world that you're building.
And last but not least
is tip number five.
Make sure you don't lose
track of the bigger picture.
As a game designer,
this is something
that I can get stuck with.
When I'm really hyper
focused on the details,
sometimes I forget
to take a step back.
But really, you want to
be looking at the bigger
picture of your audio game.
Some of you may be
familiar with this chart.
This is the player
interest curve.
And this is a reference
that game designers
use to ensure that players
stay engaged from beginning
to end of a game.
So when you first
enter the game,
you have kind of a
really fun introduction
that gets players
hooked in your game.
And, of course, you
want to make sure
that players end on a
high note so that they
feel like there is
a payoff at the end,
and that they didn't waste
time investing in this game.
The difficult part
is making sure
that the players are engaged
in the middle portion
of your game.
So you can't just have
a really great beginning
and then just flatten out.
Of course, you want to make sure
that the player engagement is
on an upward trajectory
until they reach the payoff.
Something that's challenging
in voice games are errors.
So the thing about using
your voice as a controller
is that players can
really say anything.
Some examples of how
this might happen
is you might have a true or
false question in a trivia
game, and they might
say something that's
completely off the rails.
You want to be thinking about
all these different edge cases
and be able to
design around them.
And sometimes it's not
even the player's fault.
Sometimes they might be trying
to test all the different edge
cases in the game.
But really, it could be that
there's too much background
noise.
And if the game is taking
in all this other audio,
you want to think about what
this user experience is.
I find it pretty frustrating
when the Google Assistant says,
I didn't catch that,
or I don't understand.
So we want to minimize
this disruption
if anything like this happens.
We need to design
around this to make sure
that players stay engaged
throughout the game,
like I showed you in the
player interest curve.
So to recap, here are
the five design tips
I walked you through today.
The first one was defining
the core mechanic of the game.
And I brought up two
examples of games.
So trivia games
and maybe an RPG.
Think about how
challenging your game
is to device on
this voice platform.
The second one is
setting the stage
or identifying who the
narrator of your voice game is.
The third one is writing a
dialogue between the Google
Assistant, or the
narrator, and the players.
And also, you want to be
prototyping by role-playing
to make sure there aren't
any holes in your script.
The fourth one is
layering in sound design
to the dialogue with background
music and sound effects.
And lastly, we want to
make sure as designers
that we're keeping an
eye on the bigger picture
to ensure that users stay
engaged throughout the game.
So now that you have some tips
that you can start off with,
you can design your
own voice games
using something called
Actions on Google.
You can follow this link
and also find more resources
that you can use to
kickstart your voice game.
Next, we're going
to switch gears,
and Stewart's going to share
how you can grow with Firebase.
STEWART MILES:
I'm Stewart Miles.
And I'm a lead on the
Firebase for Games team.
And I'm here to talk about
growing your game in Firebase.
So what is Firebase?
Hands up.
Anyone know what
Firebase is in the room?
Oh, wow.
We've got a lot of
Firebase users in here.
That's really awesome.
So Firebase is a mobile
development platform
from Google that extends
Google Cloud Platform.
Firebase products are
designed so that you do not
need a custom server between
your game clients and Google
Cloud.
So you can build many
connected games primarily
by writing client-side code.
It's pretty cool.
We have 1 and 1/2 million
monthly active apps
currently using Firebase.
And this includes everything
from small one-person startups,
all the way up to
massive enterprises.
They're all relying on
Firebase to just make
their lives a lot easier.
And this also includes
game developers.
So thank you to all
the game developers,
including you guys in this
room, for taking that journey
with us.
So Firebase supports iOS,
Android, and the web.
And we also provide admin
SDKs for your servers.
I'll walk you through how
Firebase can help along
with each step of the
game development process,
using our demo game
called Mecha Hamster.
So we wanted to just build
a really, really simple game
where the player navigates
mazes with a hamster ball.
They start at the
starting point.
They try and navigate
through some traps and things
like that.
And they get to the end.
After we had a rough
idea for the design,
we decided to start
building the game.
So we chose the Unity SDK.
And Unity is the engine as
a whole to develop the game.
However, Firebase integrates
easily into iOS or Android
games, whether you're a C++
developer and you've got a C++
engine, or Unity.
As of today also, if
you're a C++ developer,
we've open sourced C++ SDK.
So you'll have the option to
integrate that into your games.
This provides visibility
into your code,
enables control over
fixes and improvements,
and allows you to [? port ?]
functionality to new platforms
as well.
So we wanted players in our game
to be to create new content,
just like game designers.
So we started off by building
a level editor in the game that
enables you to design maps.
And it just saved
data to local storage.
This was great, but
it didn't enable
us to have data
shared between players
when we deploy the game.
So we decided to use the
Firebase real-time database
to store the map data.
Since the real-time database
can also notify clients
when data changes,
it would be possible
for us to add collaborative
editing features, like Google
Docs, in the future.
So next, we configured our
Firebase project in Unity.
We designed.
We navigated to a web browser,
went to the Firebase console,
created a project.
And a few seconds later,
we added the Unity app
to the project.
You can add multiple
apps to a project,
allowing multiple SKUs of a game
to share the same game data.
We wanted to target
iOS and Android,
so we registered in that for
both platforms really easily,
downloaded the configuration
files, downloaded the SDK,
and then imported the SDK, the
Firebase real-time database
plugin, into our Mecha
Hamster project in Unity.
Here are the files coming in.
And then we added the config
files to associate the Unity
project with the
Firebase project
that we had set up in
the web console earlier.
So not that many steps
to get to that point.
We then wrote in some code to
store on the map representation
in Json, so that we
can then upload that
into the real-time database.
The data was then
immediately visible
in the Firebase console,
as you can see here.
At this point, it was
possible for game designers
to author new maps and
ship those to users
without republishing the game.
We then used
Firebase's rule system
to protect access
to the map data.
This prevented
players from writing
to designer-created maps without
building a custom game server.
We didn't have to put a server
between Firebase's back-end
and each game client.
As I mentioned before,
Firebase's real-time database
can be monitored by clients.
So it's possible to build
asynchronous multiplayer games
using this scheme.
But if you're going to be able
to real-time multiplayer game,
like a MOBA, please build
your own game server.
And then, obviously, we wanted
to be able to associate user
data with user accounts.
So in this case, we're
really interested in users
being able to share maps.
So we had users sign in
at the start of the game.
Having users sign
immediately also
enabled us to add
other player data,
like high scores and
things like that,
without adding friction
later on in the game.
So handling user sign-in
yourself can be a lot of work.
So we use Firebase
Authentication for sign-in.
Authentication supports a range
of built-in identity providers,
including email and
things like that.
And now, as of a
few days ago, we
added support for Game Center
on iOS in our gaming SDKs.
So if we wanted to add
other providers later,
we could also use custom
identity providers.
So you could integrate
any identity provider
that you could think of, just
with a little bit of work.
So once a player
was logged in, it
was possible to add
support for players
to create maps and share maps.
Then we had a way to store--
we had a way to associate
data with players.
So we built a leaderboard
where players could also
post high scores.
We ended up using
Firebase's open source
Unity leaderboard API to add
leaderboards in the game.
It's an open source project that
you can grab from our website.
All we had to do was import the
Unity plug-in into our project.
And then we could
start posting scores.
It was really easy.
So since the Unity
plug-in was open source,
we also extended it
to support replays.
So in this case, we've got a
really bad player who just sits
onto one side of the screen.
And we've got the
replay happening
from the last high score
that happened in the game.
So if you've got stuff like
where users are posting data
and things like
that, you likely want
to be able to clean
it, or potentially
run some server-side
action in response
to what a player is doing.
So in this case,
Firebase integrates
with Google Cloud Functions.
And we use this to clean up
old high scores, old replays,
and things like that.
We could also do things
like potentially validate
whether or not a
user is cheating,
or handle purchases
and things like that
if we wanted to, all
using Cloud Functions.
So we wanted to make
sure our game would
work across a whole range
of devices when it shipped.
Testing across a huge
number of devices,
like Android and iOS
devices, is a lot
of work for a small team,
especially when the game is
changing rapidly.
So we decided to
use Firebase Test
Lab to run our game on physical
Android and iOS devices,
connected to machines in
Google's data centers.
Initially, we didn't
write any test code.
We just uploaded
the game and let
Test Labs, Robo, or a monkey
tester randomly tap the screen
and attempt to crash the game.
So a typical monkey tester would
just randomly tap the screen.
In the case of Robo
Test, it will actually
identify Android UI
elements and tap those.
But now, we have [INAUDIBLE]
assisted actions.
And so this will actually
use computer vision
to determine where the UI
elements are in the game.
On the left screen,
you can see random
pressing all over the place.
That's our old system.
And on the right screen, you can
see it go into the game really
quickly.
This was the [INAUDIBLE]
assisted monkey tester.
And it went through
and navigated
that UI really quickly.
It's pretty awesome.
Since we had confidence
our game was going to work,
we published it to the
App Store and Google Play.
We wanted to improve the
game, so we needed a way
to determine if
anyone was playing
and whether they would
continue to play.
So since we'd built
with Firebase,
we already had Google Analytics
integrated for Firebase.
And Google Analytics
provides a range of metrics
simply by initializing the
library out of the box,
just with a couple
of lines of code.
This data is easily available
in the Firebase console.
So we could see how long
players were continuing
to play our game,
where players are,
what platforms they're
using, demographics,
operating systems that they're
working on, and even interests.
So Google Analytics will
collect all of the data.
It's a great way of
getting data ingested.
And Firebase console provides
that easy view into your data.
But once it's
integrated, because we're
connected with Google
Cloud, all of this data
can be then streamed
into BigQuery.
So we can use BigQuery
to do some basic analysis
of the data.
So this is a really
simple example.
We wrote some SQL
to just look at
based upon which operating
system, the total number
of users per operating system.
And we ended up with results
segmented by country.
It's pretty easy.
Getting stuff into
BigQuery is great
because then you
can start processing
potentially petabytes of data.
You can train machine
learning models,
and you can do so much more.
There's so many
options with this.
You can even pull in data
from other data sources
that you have as well,
outside of Firebase.
So what if you find out
your game is losing players?
Perhaps players are reporting
problems via negative reviews.
How do you determine what
is going wrong in the field?
Well, we released Firebase
Crashalytics recently
to monitor crashes in our game.
Each crash report is visible
in the Firebase console,
along with instant rate.
You can also see
breakdowns on the type
of crashes people are seeing.
And you can even
see stack traces
that showed you exactly
where in your code
the crash is occurring.
So Crashalytics data is
also available in BigQuery.
So it's possible to take
tasks, like determining
whether crashes are happening to
high value or low value users,
and balancing that against
the cost of fixing the bug,
and to determine
whether it's easier
to just unpublish a game
for a specific device,
or put all the effort
in to fix the problem.
So we wanted to
improve our game.
So we needed more players
to gather more data.
We needed people
to be more engaged.
So we had this theory
that a lot of players
would stop playing because
they'd played through all
of the maps in the game.
So we integrated
Firebase Cloud Messaging
so that we could re-engage our
players using notifications.
So when we publish
a new map, we would
be able to send push
notifications to users
so that they could come
back into the game.
So you can do this for
any aspects of your game
at all, like new modes,
friends coming online.
There's plenty of use cases.
So in the case of
integrating Cloud Messaging,
you could just compose a
notification in the console,
select a specific set of users.
In this case, we
sent it to everyone.
The player would then see
a system notification.
If they tap on that,
it would take them
to the content in the game.
So new content, like I said,
can really be anything.
It could be a time limited
offer for in-game currency.
Anything at all.
So in cases when
players uninstall
the game, if we actually
have their email address
or we have some access
to them via social media,
we can actually send
a dynamic link to them
that would take them
straight into the game.
So when a user opens a
Firebase dynamic link,
it takes them all the way
through app installation
and will then take them
directly into the game,
without them having to go
back and find the link again.
Since we have Google
Analytics integrated,
we were then able
to run experiments
or AB tests on
players by pushing
new configuration to the game
just using Firebase Remote
Config.
Firebase Remote Config
simply stores key value pairs
so that-- they can
contain any data at all.
So for example, we could update
game balance for all users
to make the game easier,
or just for users
who are having
trouble completing
the first few maps of the game.
Also, since we integrated
Google Analytics for Firebase,
it was possible
to see conversions
from ads automatically
without integrating a new SDK.
This also made it possible
to target player audiences
in Google Analytics.
So if you're not
building a demo,
you probably want to get
paid for your hard work.
So if you want to
figure out when
to show in-game offers,
ads, or organize your store
to maximize the chance a
player will generate revenue,
it can be pretty hard.
So if you're already
using Google Analytics,
it's possible to enable
a product we have
called Firebase Predictions.
It's a single click
in the console.
And that identifies players who
are likely to churn or spend
in your game.
This can be used as a guide to
run experiments and maximize
revenue.
So for example, Rockbite
Games used predictions
to segment their
players into groups
based upon their chance of
spending or not spending.
They then used
Firebase Remote Config
to change their in-app
store differently
for players who are likely
to spend versus not spend.
They discovered players in
the likely to spend group
made more in-app purchases
if chests were featured
at the top of the store.
Rockbite also gave users in
the unlikely to spend segment
the option of viewing an
ad to get in-game currency.
Firebase as a whole helped
Rockbite boost revenue by 25%.
Halfbrick Games also used
Firebase to increase revenue.
They constructed
an experiment where
they gifted users credits.
The control group
received no credits.
One group received
credits at level three.
Third group received
credits when they
were in the will-churn segment.
Users in the
will-churn test group
had a 20% increase in
seven-day retention
versus the other segments.
So it's possible to leverage
the power of machine learning
easily to build in-app purchase
flows and ad experiences
with Firebase Predictions.
Now, if you don't want
to customize things,
it's possible to just turn
on AdMob Smart Segmentation
if you've got an AdMob
integrated into your game.
This will automatically
show ads to players
who are predicted to not spend,
and not show ads to players--
show ads to players who are
predicted not spend, and not
show ads to players who
are predicted to spend.
So AdMob also does all of the AB
testing automatically for you.
It's really easy to
integrate and use.
So if you want to learn
more about Firebase at GDC,
we've got a deep dive
into Google Cloud Platform
and Firebase on Wednesday.
There's actually an entire
day dedicated to Google Cloud
Platform on Wednesday.
We're also speaking at
the Google Expo booth
Wednesday at 11:30.
And we'll be covering how to
use Firebase data to optimize
games.
And on Thursday
at 2:00 PM, we'll
be covering more Firebase
features in Mecha Hamster.
OK.